Shure: 你欺负我吧 啊
Shure: Are you bullying me, huh?
Shure: 好以后分你一半
Shure: Fine, I'll share half with you later.
Shure: 你会carry一下吗
Shure: Can you carry a bit?
女嘉宾:原来环球在通州区
Female Guest: So, Universal Studios is in Tongzhou District.
Shure:  开
Shure: Start.
Shure:  我们的500万还没开奖呢
Shure: Our 5 million hasn't been drawn yet.
女嘉宾:坐地铁来说
Female Guest: Speaking of the subway.
Shure: 今晚
Shure: Tonight.
女嘉宾:有一站是通州北岳
Female Guest: There's a station called Tongzhou Beiyue.
Alice: 没错我们就是排
Alice: That's right, we're just lining up.
Alice: 我就是排舞的时候跳的最哎
Alice: I was the best at dancing during the rehearsal.
刘婷:唉你们排舞不会也是为了这个吧
Liu Ting: Hey, did you guys rehearse just for this?
Alice: 没排成 没排成
Alice: It didn't work out, it didn't work out.
Alice: 排了一下午
Alice: We rehearsed all afternoon.
Shure:  你要你要
Shure: You want, you want.
Shure:  刮完刮我是不是还得把20给你报销了
Shure: After I finish, do I still have to reimburse you the 20 bucks?
女嘉宾:这个背景真的很劣宗
Female Guest: This background is really lousy.
女嘉宾:不觉得吗哈哈
Female Guest: Don't you think so? Haha.
Shure的女友:当然了不然呢
Shure's GF: Of course, what else?
Shure的女友:怎么了你不想
Shure's GF: What's wrong, don't you want to?
Alice: 好甜
Alice: So sweet.
Alice:开嗑
Alice: Let's start.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
女嘉宾:这个背景特别劣宗
Female Guest: This background is particularly lousy.
女嘉宾:你要是单独一个人坐在那就是后彩
Female Guest: If you were sitting there alone, it would be even more colorful.
Shure:  我我我给你报给你报
Shure: I'll reimburse you, I'll reimburse you.
女嘉宾:直接问你有哪位心动女嘉宾
Female Guest: Just ask if there's any girl you fancy.
女嘉宾:然后什么给谁发了短信
Female Guest: And who did you text?
Jack: 可以啊
Jack: Sure.
Jake: 是是是
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
女嘉宾:然后说你的
Female Guest: And then say yours.
Jack: 怎么玩
Jack: How to play?
女嘉宾:x没有选择你
Female Guest: X didn't choose you.
Jack: 可以啊可以啊
Jack: Sure, sure.
Alice: 你真漂亮
Alice: You're really pretty.
Jake: 上墙了对
Jake: It's on the wall, right?
Alice: 我是不是太直白了
Alice: Am I being too straightforward?
刘婷:你说什么
Liu Ting: What did you say?
Alice: 干嘛
Alice: What's up?
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's okay.
Alice: 翻白眼干嘛
Alice: Why are you rolling your eyes?
刘婷:没翻白眼
Liu Ting: I didn't roll my eyes.
Shure: 夸你呢夸你呢
Shure: I'm complimenting you, really.
Jake: 太专业了
Jake: So professional.
Shure的女友:嚯所以意思就是他配不上对吧
Shunv: Whoa, so you mean he's not good enough, right?
刘婷:我没说话
Liu Ting: I didn't say anything.
Alice: 我没说话
Alice: I didn't say anything.
刘婷:我跟你说
Liu Ting: Let me tell you.
刘婷:你看看你
Liu Ting: Look at you.
女嘉宾:当他呃就是
Female Guest: When he, uh, just...
Shure: 你怎么老老老多想呢
Shure: Why do you always overthink things?
Jack: 想想拍氛围感的可以可以那个
Jack: Think about creating the right atmosphere, you can do that.
刘婷:口不择言
Liu Ting: Talking nonsense.
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What?
刘婷:童颜无忌 童言无忌
Liu Ting: Childlike innocence, childlike words.
Alice:童言无忌
Alice: Childlike words.
Alice: 我比你大
Alice: I'm older than you.
Alice: 我是你姐
Alice: I'm your big sister.
Shure: 这念  那个是什么字
Shure: How do you pronounce this? What's this character?
Alice: 我童言无忌
Alice: I speak with childlike innocence.
Alice: 倒返天罡
Alice: "Dao Fan Tian Gang."
Shure的女友:我不知道
Shunv: I don't know.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure的女友:习惯了吧
Shunv: You must be used to it by now.
Alice: 快点我们俩能合照一张吗
Alice: Hurry up, can we take a picture together?
Shure: 过年时候回家
Shure: When we go home for New Year.
Alice: 我我想跟她合照
Alice: 有一张很有爱的
Alice: A very loving one.
刘婷:什么叫很有
Liu Ting: What do you mean by "very loving"?
Alice: 表情给我管理好
Alice: Manage your expressions well.
Shure:  带你去吉大逛一圈来
Shure: Let me show you around Jilin University.
Shure的女友:我不想逛大学不想逛
Shunv: I don't want to tour a university, I don't want to.
Shure:  哦你不想逛
Shure: Oh, you don't want to?
Shure的女友:我不想逛
Shunv: I don't want to.
Shure:  那算了
Shure: Alright, never mind.
刘婷:一定要带着眼镜吗
Liu Ting: Do I have to wear glasses?
Shure:  本来说想带你去吉大溜达一圈
Shure: I was thinking of taking you for a stroll around Jilin University.
Shure:  因为我去哪我都特别喜欢逛大学
Shure: Because wherever I go, I really like visiting universities.
Shure:  我也不知道为什么
Shure: I don't even know why.
Shure的女友:我我没有
Shure's GF: I-I don't have...
Shure的女友:没有这种
Shure's GF: I don't have that.
Shure: 你怎么
Shure: How could you...
女嘉宾:雌雄双煞一样
Female Guest: Like a dynamic duo.
女嘉宾:你们俩干什么呢
Female Guest: What are you two doing?
Jack: 黑白双煞 黑白双煞
Jack: Black and white duo, black and white duo.
Alice: 快点
Alice: Hurry up.
Shure: 这你就不知道了吧
Shure: You don't know about this, do you?
Alice: 这墙是
Alice: This wall is...
Alice:没动作啊
Alice: No movement at all.
女嘉宾:哇
Female Guest: Wow.
Alice: 能不能搂着我呀来
Alice: Can you hold me? Come on.
Jack: 那边叫神仙眷侣这边叫黑白双煞
Jack: Over there they call it a divine couple, here it's the black and white duo.
Alice: 哈哈来吧
Alice: Haha, come on.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What's this?
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
女嘉宾:啊 我
Female Guest: Ah, I...
Alice: 好僵硬
Alice: So stiff.
女嘉宾:是我的
Female Guest: It's mine.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jack: 对被迫营业啊
Jack: Yeah, forced to do business.
女嘉宾:太难看了
Female Guest: So ugly.
Jack: 这个这个这个这个这叫被迫营业啊
Jack: This, this, this, this, this is called forced business.
Jack: 这个叫被迫营业啊
Jack: This is called forced business.
Alice:一看就不是真情侣知道吗
Alice: You can tell they're not a real couple, you know?
Jack: 这个这个叫黑白双煞
Jack: This, this is called the black and white duo.
刘婷:什么 这个真情侣不完蛋了吗
Liu Ting: What, a real couple would be doomed?
Alice:我真笑死
Alice: I'm really dying of laughter.
Jack: 上面在写个匾
Jack: Put a plaque up there.
Jack: 被迫营业啊黑白双煞
Jack: Forced business, black and white duo.
Jack: 然后
Jack: And then...
Jack: 哎  哎
Jack: Hey, hey.
Jack: 画风突变
Jack: The style suddenly changed.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:这才真情侣
Alice: Now this is a real couple.
刘婷:男士没了
Liu Ting: The guy is gone.
Alice:跟你就拍不出这种感觉
Alice: We can't get this kind of feeling with you.
Shure: 好好好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
刘婷:因为我们本来就是就是
Liu Ting: Because we are, we are...
Shure: 怎么
Shure: What...
Alice:低智哈哈哈
Alice: Dumb, hahaha
刘婷:契约
Liu Ting: Contract
Shure的女友:你可以带女朋友吗
Shure's GF: Can you bring your girlfriend?
Alice: 哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
刘婷:就是行婚你知道吗
Liu Ting: It's a marriage of convenience, you know?
Shure的女友:没事
Shure's GF: It's okay
Shure:  什么东西
Shure: What are you talking about?
Alice:我靠 谁跟你行婚
Alice: No way, who's going to marry you like that?
Alice:我行婚都不想跟你行婚你去死吧你啊
Alice: Even if it's a convenience marriage, I wouldn't marry you. Get lost!
Shure: 怎么啦
Shure: What's going on?
Alice:来低智
Alice: Come on, dumb
Shure的女友:感觉要加点糖浆
Shure's GF: Feels like it needs some syrup
Alice:我现在就来驯服我的手脚
Alice: I'm going to tame my hands and feet now
Shure: 糖浆真没有这个
Shure: There's no syrup for this
Shure:  你要不那个葡萄什么的
Shure: How about some grapes or something?
Alice:没耳机啊
Alice: No headphones?
Shure的女友:他那个果香很重
Shure's GF: It has a strong fruity aroma
刘婷:这个动作会
Liu Ting: This action will
Shure的女友:但是他的甜味有点欠缺
Shure's GF: But its sweetness is a bit lacking
Jake:倔强 倔强青铜
Jake: Stubborn, stubborn bronze
Shure的女友:然后你正常的话
Shure's GF: And then normally
Alice:低智
Alice: Dumb
Shure: 有旺仔牛奶
Shure: There's Want Want milk
Shure:  有旺仔牛奶
Shure:  想想还要什么
Shure: Think if you need anything else
Katrina: 那我要带眼睛
Katrina: Then I need to bring glasses
Alice:他天天给我发这个
Alice: He sends me this every day
刘婷:挺好玩的这个
Liu Ting: This is pretty fun
Katrina: 呵呵我拿瓶饮料
Katrina: Haha, I'll grab a drink
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 说什么呢我刚刚
Katrina: What was I saying just now?
Alice:我不要跟你跳这个
Alice: I don't want to dance this with you
Alice:我这机器掉了我给你说啊你今天你就走不了了
Alice: If this machine breaks, I'm telling you, you won't be able to leave today
Shure的女友:我感有点碍事
Shure's GF: I feel a bit obstructed
刘婷:这个
Liu Ting: This
Alice:我要这个
Alice: I want this
Alice:学不会啊
Alice: Can't learn it
刘婷:左人 右 左右各一个人
Liu Ting: Left person, right person, one on each side
Shure: 后期这边全打码
Shure: We'll blur this part in post-production
Alice:你能教我吗
Alice: Can you teach me?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure:  啊没事没事
Shure: Ah, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:那带什么眼镜
Jake: Then, what kind of glasses should I wear?
Alice:我觉得他不会
Alice: I don't think he knows how.
Shure的女友:我也想问啊
Shure's GF: I wanted to ask too.
女嘉宾:不行 接受不了你们俩个人
Female Guest: No way, I can't accept both of you.
Shure的女友:我也想问啊
Shure's GF: I wanted to ask too.
Shure:  没事那你给贡献一下也是可以的
Shure: It's okay, you can contribute too.
刘婷:兄弟兄弟
Liu Ting: Bro, bro.
Katrina: 还是晚上这种柔和一点的光拍的好看一点
Katrina: It's better to shoot with softer light at night.
Alice:没兄弟了
Alice: No more bros.
Shure的女友:不可以
Shure's GF: No, you can't.
Shure的女友:我不可以
Shure's GF: I can't.
Alice:你问我问Lucia跳不跳
Alice: Are you asking me if Lucia will dance?
Alice: Lucia
Alice: Lucia?
Shure:  草
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake:好给您处理好吗
Jake: Alright, let me handle it for you, okay?
Shure: 给你眼睛打个码
Shure: I'll blur your eyes.
Alice:你想参加我们的低智小视频吗
Alice: Do you want to join our dumb little video?
Lucia:什么低智小视频
Lucia: What dumb little video?
Alice:来来来 你让她看
Alice: Come, come, let her see.
女嘉宾:等一下我把这个连上
Female Guest: Wait a second, I'll connect this.
Alice: 声音放大
Alice: Turn up the volume.
Jake: 这样你们这段声音可以闭掉是吧
Jake: So you can mute this part of the audio, right?
女嘉宾:最后最后
Female Guest: Last one, last one.
Shure的女友:不 图像也不可以
Shure's GF: No, the image can't be shown either.
Jake: 图像也不可以
Jake: The image can't be shown either.
Lucia:哇 这个转圈好厉害哦
Lucia: Wow, that spin is amazing.
Shure: 图像可以可以
Shure: The image can be shown, it can.
Jake: 为啥
Jake: Why?
Shure的女友:不可以
Shure's GF: No, it can't.
Jake: 行了全打码吧
Jake: Alright, blur everything then.
Lucia:你们怎么做到了
Lucia: How did you manage that?
Lucia:怎么拍的时候刚好边上没人呢
Lucia: How did you shoot it without anyone around?
Alice:巧合
Alice: Just a coincidence.
Shure的女友:声音其实没问题但是图像不可以
Shure's GF: The sound is actually okay, but the image can't be shown.
刘婷:退后 左右左往右跳步然后
Liu Ting: Step back, left, right, left, jump to the right, then...
Shure: 哦她要脸
Shure: Oh, she wants her face shown.
Jake:好好那也可以
Jake: Okay, that works too.
Lucia:哇
Lucia: Wow.
男嘉宾:咱俩聊聊
Male Guest: Let's have a chat.
Jake:这是市场需要的
Jake: This is what the market needs.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's impressive.
Alice:受不了了
Alice: I can't take it anymore.
男嘉宾:第一视角第二视角
Male Guest: First-person view, second-person view.
刘婷:要加入我们吗
Liu Ting: Want to join us?
Jake: 对 那确实
Jake: Yes, that's true.
男嘉宾:太有必要了
Male Guest: It's very necessary.
Lucia:可以啊
Lucia: Sure.
刘婷:快 你学好吗
Liu Ting: Quick, did you learn it?
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What?
我们那天跳舞应该找他们的哦
We should have asked them to dance with us that day.
Alice: 怎么记住啊
Alice: How to remember it?
Alice:不是我们 是他这种低智视频
Alice: Not us, it's his low-IQ videos.
女嘉宾:别别不要给我乱戴帽子
Female Guest: No, no, don't put labels on me.
Alice: 祖奶
Alice: Grandma.
Jake: 来来来我要看我要看
Jake: Come on, come on, I want to see it.
Jake: 导演把导演版拿出来
Jake: Director, bring out the director's cut.
刘婷:拍低智 过来 行
Liu Ting: Filming low-IQ stuff, come over, okay.
Shure: 搞一个
Shure: Let's do one.
女嘉宾:让他
Female Guest: Let him.
Alice:让他拍哈哈哈哈
Alice: Let him film it, hahaha.
Alice:干嘛
Alice: What?
Shure的女友:就莫名其妙的就开始
Shure's GF: It just started out of nowhere.
Alice:能不能教教我呀 我记不住
Alice: Can you teach me? I can't remember.
Shure的女友:本来我计划我能喝一个一个学期的
Shure's GF: Originally, I planned to drink for a whole semester.
Shure的女友:然后然后
Shure's GF: And then...
刘婷:没事
Liu Ting: It's okay.
Shure的女友:然后因为你天天在那里
Shure's GF: And then because you were there every day...
刘婷:背对着他
Liu Ting: Turn your back to him.
Alice: 背对着他 背对啊
Alice: Turn your back to him, turn around.
Shure的女友:让我给你带一瓶
Shure's GF: Let me bring you a bottle.
刘婷:背对着他
Liu Ting: Turn your back to him.
Shure的女友:给你带一瓶
Shure's GF: I'll bring you a bottle.
Shure的女友:搞得我现在觉得少点东西
Shure's GF: Now I feel like something is missing.
刘婷:然后
Liu Ting: And then...
Shure: 然后就补了
Shure: And then I made up for it.
Alice:感觉堵了
Alice: Feels like it's clogged.
Alice:这样啊哈哈哈哈
Alice: Oh, like this, hahaha.
Shure的女友:没有补没有补
Shure's GF: No refill, no refill.
Shure:  没补
Shure: No refill.
Shure的女友:喝完再说吧
Shure's GF: Let's finish drinking first.
Shure的女友:因为谁知道要待到什么时候呢
Shure's GF: Who knows how long we'll be here.
刘婷:后退 等一下
Liu Ting: Step back, wait a second.
Shure的女友:5月份 5月份开始
Shure's GF: Starting in May, in May.
Alice:这样
Alice: Oh, like this.
刘婷:这样 然后你直到啊一声
Liu Ting: Like this, then you go "ah".
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
刘婷:开始
Liu Ting: Begin.
女嘉宾:起事
Female Guest: Let's start.
Lucia:起
Lucia: Start.
Lucia:这是咱今天晚上保留节目吗
Lucia: Is this our special program for tonight?
刘婷:对 然后你
Liu Ting: Yes, then you...
Shure: 对去哪了
Shure: Where did it go?
刘婷:呃
Liu Ting: Uh...
Alice:不是
Alice: No.
刘婷:这是我们的
Liu Ting: This is ours.
Jack: 可以是可以是
Jack: It can be, it can be.
Lucia:可以是可以是
Lucia: It can be, it can be.
Alice:别
Alice: No.
Jake: 挺好挺好的
Jake: It's good, it's good.
Lucia:来我帮你拍
Lucia: Let me take a picture for you.
Shure: 你要回家了
Shure: Are you going home?
刘婷:AI识别不出来了怎么办
Liu Ting: What if AI can't recognize it?
Shure的女友:所以你明天是只要
Shure's GF: So tomorrow you only need to...
Shure: 这才八月
Shure: It's only August.
Jake: 最好让它识别出来对
Jake: It's best if it can recognize it, yes.
Lucia:这个怎么
Lucia: How about this...
Shure的女友:那你跟我回吗
Shure's GF: Will you come back with me?
刘婷:ok 你就就就是最后面那个人
Liu Ting: Ok, you are the last person in the back.
Lucia:现在就是开了
Lucia: Now it's open.
Lucia:你要不要先调一下这些各种 参数之类的这些
Lucia: Do you want to adjust these parameters first?
刘婷:然后我们前面有两个人
Liu Ting: And we have two people in front.
Jack: 我看看没什么需要调的
Jack: Let me see, there's nothing to adjust.
刘婷:然后这个之后我们就 双臂展开
Liu Ting: Then we just spread our arms after this.
我我爸妈现在对我的包容度就是
I: My parents are now very tolerant of me...
Jack: 然后你就看你喜欢的背景就可以了
Jack: Then you just choose the background you like.
男嘉宾:最近东方没找你
Male Guest: Has Dongfang contacted you recently?
Shure的女友:你带个人回来
Shure's GF: You bring someone back.
刘婷:抓紧 你知道吧
Liu Ting: Hurry up, you know?
刘婷:展开展开我忘  我忘  我也忘了 应该是
Liu Ting: Spread out, spread out, I forgot, I forgot, I also forgot, it should be...
Shure:  啊 现在
Shure: Ah, right now?
Shure的女友:就就是因为他们
Shure's GF: It's just because of them.
Lucia:你来选择
Lucia: You make the choice.
Katrina: 就没找过我了
Katrina: They haven't contacted me at all.
Lucia:或者你刚刚就是帮大家拍的时候
Lucia: Or maybe when you were just helping everyone take photos.
Lucia:你觉得哪里好看你就站哪里就行
Lucia: You can stand wherever you think looks good.
Shure的女友:已经很片面地了解了我的性取向
Shure's GF: They already have a very superficial understanding of my sexual orientation
Shure的女友:所以现在他们的感觉就是OK
Shure's GF: So now they feel like it's okay.
Shure的女友:你带个人就回来
Shure's GF: You just bring someone back.
Alice: 不是 这什么时候出 什么时候收啊
Alice: No, when does this come out and when does it end?
Shure的女友:我猜有人带什么东西
Shure's GF: I guess someone is bringing something.
男嘉宾:之前老师跟我说多了个方向让我可以选
Male Guest: A teacher told me before that I have another direction to choose from.
Shure: 是人就行了呗呢
Shure: As long as it's a person, right?
刘婷:协调一点嘛
Liu Ting: Coordinate a bit.
Katrina: 哪个浙大老师吗
Katrina: Which teacher from Zhejiang University?
Shure: 我满足了吗
Shure: Have I fulfilled it?
Alice: 不协调啊
Alice: Not coordinated.
Lucia: OK OK来试试吧
Lucia: OK OK, let's try it.
Shure: 大题满足是吧
Shure: Big question fulfilled, right?
Alice: 不是这什么时候出什么时候收
Alice: No, when does this come out and when does it end?
Shure: 可以考虑
Shure: Can consider it.
Lucia: 不是他咋又黑了
Lucia: No, why is it dark again?
刘婷:来 come on
Liu Ting: Come on, come on.
Katrina: 图形图
Katrina: Graphic, graph.
Lucia: OK OK OK
Lucia: OK OK OK.
Shure的女友:就是从我带猫回家的时候然后我爸妈说
Shure's GF: Since I brought the cat home, my parents said...
Shure的女友:OK啊我回家
Shure's GF: OK, I'll go home.
Shure的女友:我带个小朋友回家
Shure's GF: I'll bring a kid home.
Shure的女友:然后回家之后我妈说我就知道
Shure's GF: Then after going home, my mom said, "I knew it."
Shure: 吓死我以为你说小朋友是是我
Shure: You scared me, I thought you were saying the kid was me.
Alice: 啊我觉得太抽象了
Alice: Ah, I think it's too abstract.
Lucia: 拍了好多张
Lucia: Took a lot of photos.
Shure: 啊啊啊
Shure: Ah ah ah.
Shure的女友:没有我带猫
Shure's GF: No, I brought the cat.
刘婷:那就是
Liu Ting: That's just...
Shure的女友:我妈说我就知道
Shure's GF: My mom said, "I knew it."
Shure的女友:你说小朋友肯定不是什么人
Shure's GF: You said the kid is definitely not a person.
Shure的女友:嗯他们俩在那吵也不是吵
Shure's GF: Hmm, they were arguing but not really arguing.
Lucia:这个光感好像不太用
Lucia: The lighting doesn't seem quite right.
Alice:啊 不是这个
Alice: Ah, it's not this one.
Katrina: 如果想让脸要亮一点的
Katrina: If you want your face to be a bit brighter...
Shure的女友:就是友好交流
Shure's GF: It's just friendly communication.
男嘉宾:脸亮点可以还行
Male Guest: Making your face brighter is okay.
Lucia:就是这样感觉还行
Lucia: Yeah, it feels okay like this.
Shure的女友:但是就呃那个吵的矛头是针对我的
Shure's GF: But um, the argument was aimed at me.
Alice: 哎呀 不难 我学
Alice: Oh, it's not hard, I'll learn.
Jack: 但是这个
Jack: But this...
Shure的女友:他们两个在友好交流
Shure's GF: They were just having a friendly exchange.
男嘉宾:你没有你没有闪是吗
Male Guest: Did you not flash?
刘婷:踏步准备
Liu Ting: Get ready to march.
Jack: 显然没有哦
Jack: Obviously not.
Lucia:哦没按
Lucia: Oh, I didn't press it.
刘婷:然后对对对
Liu Ting: Then, yes, yes, yes.
刘婷:他们归位之后就左右哈哈哈
Liu Ting: After they return to their positions, just left and right, hahaha.
Lucia: 要再来一张吗
Lucia: Do you want to take another shot?
Lucia: 你看你想站哪
Lucia: See where you want to stand.
Jake: 哎你干嘛呢自闭啦
Jake: Hey, what are you doing? Feeling down?
Alice: 猫眼三姐妹
Alice: The three cat sisters.
Jake: 打游戏hello
Jake: Playing games, hello.
Jake: 你在干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake: 睡觉啊
Jake: Sleeping?
Lucia:我说那边OK
Lucia: I said over there is OK.
刘婷:如何学如何了
Liu Ting: How's the learning going?
Jake: 那我们下去玩吧
Jake: Then let's go downstairs and play.
Alice:我再记一会
Alice: I'll remember it for a while longer.
Jake: 哈哈哈 不知道
Jake: Hahaha, don't know.
Jake: 不知道带着眼镜下去采一点
Jake: Don't know, wear glasses and go collect a bit.
Shure: 太E了是吗
Shure: Too easy, right?
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Jake: 或者你要休息啊
Jake: Or do you want to rest?
刘婷:来给我背一遍啊
Liu Ting: Come recite it for me.
刘婷:背过去
Liu Ting: Recite it.
Jake: 发烧了 好 是
Jake: Got a fever? Okay, yes.
Alice:背过去
Alice: Recite it.
Shure: 那现在是
Shure: So now it's...
Jake:好 是 发烧了 唉  好
Jake: Okay, yes, got a fever. Sigh, okay.
Shure:  I然后底下多了两个横
Shure: And then there are two more lines at the bottom.
Alice:起 起事 右 左 右 左 踏步
Alice: Start, start, right, left, right, left, step.
Shure:  上面那横还没多出来呢是吧
Shure: The line at the top hasn't appeared yet, right?
男嘉宾:看来她们后面要跳舞
Male Guest: Looks like they're going to dance later.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈打游戏
Jake: Hahaha, playing games.
Jake: 下去打去哈哈哈
Jake: Go play downstairs, hahaha.
男嘉宾:让他把这张帘放下他们后面会动
Male Guest: Let him drop this curtain, they'll move behind it.
Lucia:对对对我也想说
Lucia: Yes, yes, I was thinking the same.
Jake:都在玩呢有啥差别
Jake: Everyone's playing, what's the difference?
女嘉宾:这个不行
Female Guest: This won't do.
Lucia:你这个入镜的刚好都是些可乐和酒
Lucia: You're just in the shot with some coke and booze.
Alice:然后 你 回来
Alice: Then you, come back.
Lucia:显得你特别像一个调酒师或者什么的
Lucia: You look like a bartender or something.
Alice:我
Alice: I...
男嘉宾:啊可以可以
Male Guest: Ah, that's fine, that's fine.
Lucia:刚好
Lucia: Just right.
Katrina:  这一块还有挺有氛围感的
Katrina: This part has quite a vibe.
Lucia:这今晚上能练会这个吗
Lucia: Can we practice this tonight?
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
刘婷:实在不行咱还是跳舞吧
Liu Ting: If it doesn't work, let's just dance.
Alice:不行你太弱智
Alice: No, you're too stupid.
男嘉宾:我给你拍一个
Male Guest: I'll take a picture for you.
Shure:  咋了
Shure: What's up?
Lucia:你本来就这么大
Lucia: You're already this big.
Lucia:哈哈不是我摄影技术问题
Lucia: Haha, it's not my photography skills.
Shure的女友:没有我就是感觉
Shure's GF: No, I just feel...
Shure的女友:感觉很久没见你了
Shure's GF: It feels like I haven't seen you in a while.
Lucia:哈哈 跑了 哈
Lucia: Haha, ran away, haha.
刘婷:左右左右左分散
Liu Ting: Left, right, left, disperse.
Shure的女友:但其实没有
Shure's GF: But actually, no.
Shure: 想我了呗
Shure: Missed me, huh?
Alice: 我又不用分散
Alice: I don't need to disperse.
Lucia:跑了相机不好相相机没拍出你的这个
Lucia: Ran away, the camera didn't capture your...
Lucia:这个这个英姿飒爽是吧
Lucia: Your heroic posture, right?
Jake:在这里在这里
Jake: It's here, it's here.
Lucia:哈哈哈 这咋 哎
Lucia: Hahaha, how's this, oh.
Katrina:  我拿相
Katrina: I'll take the camera.
Lucia:相机没拍出你的英姿飒爽
Lucia: The camera didn't capture your heroic posture.
刘婷:起右左右左踏步
Liu Ting: Start, right, left, right, left, step.
刘婷:这不关你的事
Liu Ting: This is none of your business.
Alice: 啊这个哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ah, this, hahaha.
刘婷:这个哈哈
Liu Ting: This, haha.
刘婷:你 你不是这个苗子我天呢
Liu Ting: You, you're not the right type, my gosh.
刘婷:如何
Liu Ting: How is it?
Lucia:特别好
Lucia: Really good.
Alice:好像学会了又好像没学会
Alice: Seems like you learned it but also didn't.
Alice: 你你要不要参与我们
Alice: Do you want to join us?
Jake:早来一点 我靠
Jake: Come earlier, oh my gosh.
Shure: 看看谢彬竹在干嘛
Shure: Let's see what Xie Binzhu is doing.
Alice:脸 哈哈哈Lucia你来嘛
Alice: Face, hahaha. Lucia, come on.
Shure:  应该是给女朋友打电话吧可能
Shure: He should be calling his girlfriend, maybe.
Alice: 我是摸屁股这个
Alice: I'm grabbing the butt, this.
Alice: 哈哈哈不是哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha, no, hahaha.
Shure: 啊没有没有
Shure: Oh, no, no.
Lucia:不行
Lucia: No way.
Alice:你是哈哈那个
Alice: You're the haha one.
Shure:  来吧
Shure: Come on.
刘婷:这是不是太近了
Liu Ting: Isn't this too close?
Lucia:如何一句话劝退别人是吗
Lucia: How to discourage someone in one sentence, right?
Jake: 让我整这个
Jake: Let me handle this.
Shure的女友:嗨帅哥
Shure's GF: Hi, handsome.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Katrina:  哈哈哈还教摆pose
Katrina: Hahaha, still teaching how to pose.
Shure的女友:加个VX
Shure's GF: Add me on WeChat.
Shure: 哈哈哈 他他有可能烧的
Shure: Hahaha, he might be confused.
Shure:  还没没有反应过来
Shure: Still hasn't reacted.
Nicous: 我怕把你吓着了
Nicous: I'm afraid I'll scare you.
Shure的女友:你别扇别扇别扇别扇别扇
Shure's GF: Don't fan, don't fan, don't fan, don't fan, don't fan.
刘婷:就是可能会伤害他的眼睛
Liu Ting: It might hurt his eyes.
Lucia:伤害他的眼镜 啊 OK
Lucia: Hurt his glasses? Ah, OK.
Alice: 就这样蹦来蹦去吗
Alice: Just jump around like this?
Jake:见证一下
Jake: Witness this.
Nicous: 关健是他本忘了他叫什么
Nicous: The key is he forgot his name.
Alice: 我连个兜都没有
Alice: I don't even have a pocket.
Alice: 这别我腰上的
Alice: Attach it to my waist.
Nicous: 找到修硕都没听清
Nicous: Even Shure didn't hear it clearly.
Shure的女友:你没有存我备注吗那时候
Shure's GF: Didn't you save my contact back then?
Lucia:啊 不过这个就是容易掉下来
Lucia: Ah, but this is easy to fall off.
Alice:他抖音上全是这种低智小视频
Alice: His Douyin is full of these low-IQ short videos.
Shure: L O R
Jake: 哦 啊 哦 不是就是我 哦
Jake: Oh ah oh, no, it's just me, oh
刘婷:不是这是我网
Liu Ting: No, it's my internet
刘婷:哦我网上收集的低智数据
Liu Ting: Oh, I collected this low IQ data online
Lucia:OK
Lucia: OK
Shure的女友:哦
Shure's GF: Oh
Alice: 低智太奶这就是
Alice: Low IQ grandma, that's what it is
Shure的女友:不是
Shure's GF: No
Nicous: 你加我嘛
Nicous: Add me
Shure: 不用了不用了
Shure: No need, no need
Katrina:  哦哦对
Katrina: Oh, oh right
Shure的女友:没关系删了之后就不用加了
Shure's GF: It's okay, you don't need to add after deleting
Shure的女友:哈哈什么事情
Shure's GF: Haha, what's the matter
Shure的女友:修硕不能知道呀
Shure's GF: Shure can't know
刘婷:然后到位踏步
Liu Ting: Then just march in place
Shure:  什么东西啊
Shure: What is it
Shure的女友:没事
Shure's GF: It's nothing
Lucia:迅速进入角色
Lucia: Quickly get into character
Shure: 嗨 这都是我们配的一环
Shure: Hey, this is all part of our act
Shure: 哈哈哈没有没有
Shure: Haha, no, no
Shure:  我发现
Shure: I found
Shure: 我戴上你这个眼镜之后你变得文明了些
Shure: After I put on your glasses, you became more civilized
Shure:  怎么有人驾着的开始
Shure: How did someone start driving
刘婷:你看一下位置
Liu Ting: Look at the position
刘婷:这这这那
Liu Ting: This, this, that
刘婷:我我我侧面侧侧过来侧过来
Liu Ting: I, I, turn sideways, turn sideways
Katrina: 哈哈哈看哪光好
Katrina: Haha, see where the light is good
Shure:  也很帅
Shure: Also very handsome
Jack: 这这黄哪光都那样
Jack: This, this, the light is the same
Shure: 哦你记不记得人有次军训去男生宿舍那次
Shure: Oh, do you remember that time we went to the boys' dorm during military training
Alice: 那这边不就没地了
Alice: Then there would be no place here
Shure的女友:哦我碰到你了吗
Shure's GF: Oh, did I bump into you
Shure的女友:我没有碰到你吧
Shure's GF: I didn't bump into you, right
Shure:   那个那谁
Shure: That, that guy
Shure:  有人给我啊
Shure: Someone gave it to me
Shure:  你喊我给你送东西
Shure: You called me to deliver something to you
Shure:  然后你说你放在那个男生宿舍就行
Shure: Then you said to just leave it in the boys' dorm
Shure:  我最开始以为我没寻思你在
Shure: At first, I didn't think you were there
Shure:  我本来想着就是光着膀子就过去了
Shure: I initially thought I'd just go over shirtless
Shure:  你知道吧
Shure: You know, right?
Shure: 后来
Shure: Later,
Shure的女友:我没有我不
Shure's GF: I didn't, I don't.
Shure的女友:我印象我没有碰到你
Shure's GF: I don't remember meeting you.
Shure的女友:那次是因为我们当时社会实践
Shure's GF: That time it was because we had a community project.
Shure的女友:然后要开个会嘛
Shure's GF: And we had to have a meeting.
Shure的女友:然后整个组的话是只有我跟培训员
Shure's GF: And in the whole group, it was just me and the trainer.
Shure的女友:我们两个女生
Shure's GF: We were the only two girls.
Shure的女友:然后培训员当时不在学校
Shure's GF: And the trainer wasn't at school.
Shure的女友:就只有我了
Shure's GF: So it was just me.
Shure的女友:然后约会议室没有约到
Shure's GF: We couldn't book the meeting room.
Shure的女友:说OK那个男生宿舍啊
Shure's GF: So we said, okay, let's do it in the boys' dorm.
Shure的女友:反正我能去
Shure's GF: Anyway, I can go.
Shure的女友:反正我那个头发无所谓了
Shure's GF: Anyway, my hair didn't matter.
Shure的女友:当时刚剪掉特别短
Shure's GF: I had just cut it really short.
Katrina:  哇哦哈哈哈
Katrina: Wow, haha.
Lucia:哇哦哈哈
Lucia: Wow, haha.
Katrina:  红点是什么
Katrina: What’s the red dot?
Shure的女友:然后就完全可以去
Shure's GF: And then it was totally fine for me to go.
Katrina: 啊 对焦
Katrina: Ah, focus.
Katrina:  太专业了
Katrina: So professional.
Alice:他的座右铭就是看低智视频
Alice: His motto is to watch low IQ videos.
Katrina: 但就第一天用了知道吗这个后来就没有
Katrina: But you know, I used it only on the first day and then never again.
Alice:想低智人生
Alice: Thinking low IQ life.
Lucia:哈哈我以为是享高智人生呢
Lucia: Haha, I thought it was enjoying high IQ life.
Alice:哈哈我以为是想高智人生
Alice: Haha, I thought it was thinking high IQ life.
Jack: 你们难道你们并不是
Jack: You guys, aren't you...
Shure的女友:然后我在这跟个景点然后就是
Shure's GF: And then I was there like a tourist spot, and then...
Shure的女友:我基本上他宿舍周围我认识的人
Shure's GF: Basically, around his dorm, the people I knew...
Katrina:  我们太随便了
Katrina: We were so casual.
Shure的女友:然后都要过来啊
Shure's GF: They would all come over.
Shure的女友:跟我打个招呼
Shure's GF: And say hi to me.
Shure的女友:然后你还叫我一下
Shure's GF: And then you called me.
Shure:  有你叫我一下
Shure: You called me.
Shure的女友:然后就是我没有叫你嘛
Shure's GF: But I didn't call you.
Shure: 你叫我给你送笔
Shure: You called me to bring you a pen.
Alice:是这样吗
Alice: Is that so?
Shure: 特意让我去打卡一下的是吧
Shure: You specifically asked me to check in, right?
Shure的女友:no no no no
Shure's GF: No no no no.
Lucia:然后下一个是我是吧
Lucia: And next is me, right?
Lucia:啊这样子
Lucia: Ah, like this.
Lucia:然后还是接着动啊哈哈
Lucia: And it keeps moving, haha.
Shure的女友:我觉得我今天这身衣服
Shure's GF: I think my outfit today...
Shure的女友:是我今天早上起来之后
Shure's GF: After I woke up this morning...
Jack: 你们这个
Jack: You guys...
Shure的女友:我在犹豫穿什么
Shure's GF: I was hesitating about what to wear.
Shure的女友:然后随便是在我那个
Shure's GF: So I just randomly picked from my...
Alice:看看
Alice: Let's see.
Shure: 摸出来的是吧
Shure: You just grabbed it, right?
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Jack: 那就这样了
Jack: So that's it.
Jake: 好嘞 能强点是吧
Jake: Okay, can it be a bit stronger?
Shure的女友:我那还有
Shure's GF: I still have...
Shure的女友:一瓶朗姆
Shure's GF: A bottle of rum.
Lucia:响亮的答复 没有
Lucia: A loud reply, no.
Shure的女友:然后大概100-200毫升的威士忌
Shure's GF: And about 100-200 ml of whiskey.
Shure的女友:一瓶
Shure's GF: One bottle.
Shure的女友:一瓶玫瑰芬
Shure's GF: One bottle of rose wine.
Shure的女友:我朋友朋友朋友给带的
Shure's GF: My friend's friend brought it.
Alice: 确实如果你不在
Alice: Indeed, if you weren't here...
Lucia:这是从零到一的进步
Lucia: This is progress from zero to one.
Shure的女友:那个山西的汾酒
Shure's GF: That Fenjiu from Shanxi.
Alice: 我是绝对不会站在这里丢人的
Alice: I definitely wouldn't be here embarrassing myself.
Katrina: 我看看DOS DQS 哦
Katrina: Let me check DOS DQS, oh.
Alice: 但是我跟你一起丢人就没有
Alice: But if I'm embarrassing myself with you...
Shure的女友:还有吗
Shure's GF: Any more?
刘婷:你特么
Liu Ting: You are...
Alice: 就没有那么丢人
Alice: It's not so embarrassing.
Shure的女友:啊没了就剩这些了
Shure's GF: Ah, that's all we have left.
Shure: 哦你说汾酒我就想起来了
Shure: Oh, you mentioned Fenjiu and it reminded me...
Lucia:说的好像我不愿意跟你一起丢人一样
Lucia: As if I don't want to embarrass myself with you.
Shure: 我宿舍里还有一瓶
Shure: I still have a bottle in my dorm.
Alice:哈哈哈但是我不愿意拉你一起丢人
Alice: Haha, but I don't want to drag you into embarrassing yourself.
Shure的女友:什么的
Shure's GF: What?
Alice:但是丢人的话我觉得就可以
Alice: But if it's embarrassing, I think...
Shure的女友:哪产的
Shure's GF: Where is it from?
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:因为汾酒它产地蛮多的
Shure's GF: Because Fenjiu has many production places.
Shure的女友:就是山东也有 山西也有应该是山西的
Shure's GF: Like Shandong has it, Shanxi has it, it should be from Shanxi.
Shure:  应该是山西的我没记错的话
Shure: It should be from Shanxi, if I remember correctly.
Shure的女友:年底带回来了
Shure's GF: Brought it back at the end of the year.
Shure的女友:我说米迪带回来的
Shure's GF: I said Midi brought it back.
Shure: 谁呀
Shure: Who?
Shure的女友:因为米迪的话那个山西他们在那边啊
Shure's GF: Because Midi, that Shanxi, they were over there.
Shure: 啊没有没有
Shure: Oh, no, no.
Jack: 实际上眼镜上泛着那
Jack: Actually, there's a glare on the glasses.
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Tasha:没有关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Shure的女友:他们当时带了大概
Shure's GF: They brought about
Alice: 那那我们这样
Alice: So, so we do it this way.
Lucia:眼睛上泛着诡异的光
Lucia: The eyes have a weird glow.
女嘉宾:眼镜上面有光
Female Guest: There's a light on the glasses.
Shure的女友:500斤的汾酒过去
Shure's GF: 500 jin of Fenjiu over.
Lucia:可还行
Lucia: That's okay.
Shure: 多少
Shure: How much?
Shure: 不要说话
Shure: Don't talk.
Lucia:哪边
Lucia: Which side?
Shure: 500斤 OK
Shure: 500 jin, okay.
Alice:好
Alice: Alright.
Shure的女友:对就是在那边往外散散
Shure's GF: Yes, just over there, distributing it.
Shure的女友:往外送送然后自己喝喝
Shure's GF: Distributing it and drinking it themselves.
Katrina:  我们一起拍 拍拍
Katrina: Let's take a picture together.
Shure的女友:然后最后就真的一点没有带回山西
Shure's GF: And finally, really didn't bring any back to Shanxi.
Shure: 牛逼
Shure: Awesome.
Alice: 怎怎么摆
Alice: How should we pose?
Alice:比心
Alice: Heart gesture.
Lucia:可以可以
Lucia: Okay, okay.
Lucia:交叉比等一下
Lucia: Cross and wait.
Alice: 我是危险中心
Alice: I'm in the danger center.
Lucia:手里一直揣着这个
Lucia: Holding this in my hand all the time.
Katrina: 我也加入
Katrina: I'll join in too.
Lucia:刚才擦手用餐巾纸擦
Lucia: Just wiped my hands with a napkin.
Lucia:咱俩还可以这样
Lucia: We can still do this.
Lucia:算了有点乱了
Lucia: Never mind, it's a bit messy.
Alice: 有点抽象
Alice: A bit abstract.
Shure: 如果哎呦
Shure: If, ouch.
Lucia:哎这个光很好
Lucia: Oh, this light is great.
Shure: 如果什么
Shure: If what?
Shure的女友:我在想如果我有足够多的朋友的话
Shure's GF: I was thinking if I had enough friends.
Lucia:有补光灯就是不一样
Lucia: Having a fill light is different.
Shure的女友:就是这种地方
Shure's GF: It's this kind of place
Alice:自己行吗要不我去送你
Alice: Can you do it yourself? How about I take you there?
Shure的女友:出来过个生日嘛
Shure's GF: Just coming out to celebrate a birthday
女嘉宾:可以
Female guest: Sure
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Shure的女友: 他们在拍照
Shure's GF: They are taking pictures
Shure的女友:他们在拍照
刘婷:噢
Liu Ting: Oh
女嘉宾:一会伸手不见五指
Female guest: Soon, you won't be able to see your hand in front of you
Katrina:  什么环节
Katrina: What segment is this?
Katrina:  现在是after party阿
Katrina: Is it the after party now?
Lucia:after party
Lucia: After party
Lucia:不是不是修硕要
Lucia: No, no, Shure needs to
Shure的女友:没有点正经音乐
Shure's GF: There's no decent music
Katrina: 唱歌
Katrina: Singing
Alice:你要从这到那要多久
Alice: How long will it take you to get from here to there?
Katrina:  啊修硕 唱歌
Katrina: Ah, Shure, sing
女嘉宾:从哪到哪
Female guest: From where to where?
Lucia:不是修硕要跳舞来着的吗
Lucia: Isn't Shure going to dance?
Alice: 就是你坐你的公交公共交通
Alice: I mean, if you take public transportation
Jake: 对啊修硕跳舞唱歌
Jake: Yeah, Shure will dance and sing
Katrina:  修硕跳舞
Katrina: Shure dance
女嘉宾:十来分钟吧
Female guest: About ten minutes
Lucia:不是修硕要干好多事来着吗
Lucia: Isn't Shure supposed to do a lot of things?
Alice:哦那还好
Alice: Oh, that's fine then
Katrina:  哈哈哈核心主力吗
Katrina: Haha, the main force, huh?
Shure: 我我我
Shure: Me, me, me
Tasha:还好
Tasha: It's fine
Alice:累吗哎等下下
Alice: Tired? Hey, wait a minute
Shure:  我怕回去他不认我了
Shure: I'm afraid he won't recognize me when I go back
Katrina: 哈哈你跳个舞她也跟你和好了
Katrina: Haha, if you dance, she'll make up with you
Alice:OK
Alice: OK
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Tasha:好
Tasha: Okay
Shure: 他分在哪跳啊
Shure: Where is he supposed to dance?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Haha
Katrina: 咱俩跳 对
Katrina: You and I dance, yes
Alice:挤眉弄眼的干什么
Alice: Why are you winking?
Shure的女友:哎 你别说他小时候学过
Shure's GF: Hey, don't say, he learned when he was a kid
Katrina:  他学什么舞种
Katrina: What type of dance did he learn?
Alice:好神经啊
Alice: So crazy.
Shure的女友:你问他咯
Shure's GF: Just ask him.
Katrina:  不会学拉丁吧
Katrina: Are you learning Latin?
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
刘婷:走走走走走走走
Liu Ting: Let's go, go, go, go, go!
Tasha: 杨老板把我感下来记我来记录生活
Tasha: Jake, record my life for me.
Shure:  老板要给你开三万块钱
Shure: The boss is offering you 30,000 yuan.
Alice:我去送他一下
Alice: I'll go see him off.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 好的他要给我开3万块钱一个月
Tasha: Alright, he's offering me 30,000 yuan a month.
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: Do you know that?
Jake:没开过
Jake: Never offered that before.
Katrina:  你再说他要破防要破防
Katrina: If you keep talking, he's gonna lose it.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:开过 但忘了
Alice: Offered before, but forgot.
Shure: 怎么啦
Shure: What's up?
Shure的女友:他刚刚已经没理我
Shure's GF: He just ignored me.
刘婷:哦哟 慢点慢点
Liu Ting: Oh, slow down, slow down.
Katrina: 抽一根
Katrina: Have a smoke.
Shure:  so
Shure: so
Shure:  你给他们发消息没理你是吧
Shure: You messaged them, and they didn't reply, right?
Alice:拜拜
Alice: Bye-bye
Jake:拜拜拜拜
Jake: Bye, bye-bye
Shure的女友:我昨天下午这个时候发消息
Shure's GFa: I sent a message at this time yesterday afternoon
Shure的女友:他们俩没有人理我到现在
Shure's GFa: Neither of them replied to me until now
Shure: 你告诉他们妈妈
Shure: Did you tell their mom?
Shure的女友:我昨天甚至还跟他们说哦
Shure's GFa: I even told them yesterday
Shure的女友:我明天下午有点事
Shure's GFa: That I had something to do tomorrow afternoon
Shure的女友:你要有什么事情的话
Shure's GFa: And if they needed anything
Shure的女友:你给我打电话就行也没有
Shure's GFa: They could just call me, but no
刘婷:哎哎哎
Liu Ting: Hey, hey, hey
Katrina: 我们预计八点结束还没有唱一首歌
Katrina: We planned to finish by eight, but we haven't even sung a song
Shure的女友:什么也没有
Shure's GFa: Nothing at all
Shure: 你看你妈妈
Shure: Look at your mom
Shure的女友:不是我不是他们在哦
Shure's GFa: No, it's not me, it's them
Shure的女友:我一直不是自从有狗就不是了
Shure's GFa: Ever since we got a dog, it's not been me
Katrina: 你还没表演你的才艺呢
Katrina: You haven't performed your talent yet
Shure的女友:自从有狗就不是了然后后来还多了只猫
Shure's GFa: Ever since we got a dog, and then later we got a cat too
Nicous: 可以啊
Nicous: Sure!
Jake: 对啊
Jake: Yeah
Lucia:没事没事
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine.
Katrina: 你的电钢琴啊
Katrina: Your electric piano.
Shure的女友:自从有狗就不是了哎你知道就是他那个猫传腹
Shure's GF: Ever since we got the dog, it's been different. You know, like his cat's FIP.
Lucia:相信您的技术
Lucia: I trust your skills.
Shure的女友:然后去看医生嘛
Shure's GF: So we went to see the vet.
Shure的女友:然后我妈去的那个
Shure's GF: And my mom went to...
Shure的女友:跟我去的不是同一家宠物医院
Shure's GF: A different pet hospital than me.
Shure的女友:然后他那个登记是
Shure's GF: And their registration...
Shure的女友:就是现在宠物的医疗登记
Shure's GF: It's like, the pet medical registration now.
Shure的女友:不是一样的就是一个连锁机构
Shure's GF: It's not the same, it's like a chain system.
Shure的女友:是一个的系统对那个
Shure's GF: It's all part of one system, you know.
Shure的女友:然后我当时我我养猫的时候
Shure's GF: When I had my cat...
Shure的女友:那个登记的就是威斯给英文
Shure's GF: The registration was given in English by Wes.
Jake: 别忘了那三首歌啊 我靠 哈哈哈
Jake: Don't forget those three songs! Oh my, haha!
Shure的女友:我妈那
Shure's GF: My mom...
Shure的女友:我那天看我体检报告了
Shure's GF: I looked at my health report that day.
Lucia:我觉得你们拍得很好很好
Lucia: I think you guys did a great job filming, really great.
Shure的女友:宠物姓名小九
Shure's GF: The pet's name was Xiao Jiu.
Shure: 哈哈哎
Shure: Haha, yeah.
Jake: 修硕你选的三首歌呢
Jake: Shure, what about the three songs you picked?
Shure: 我选的三首歌
Shure: The three songs I picked...
Katrina: 一起唱呗
Katrina: Let's sing together.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Katrina: 模特模特
Katrina: Models, models.
Shure: 收费啊收费
Shure: There's a fee, you know.
Jake: 那能是
Jake: How could there be?
Shure的女友:拍你们不行吗
Shure's GF: Can I film you guys?
Jack: 你俩是唯一正经的情侣
Jack: You two are the only official couple.
Shure: 什么叫正经
Shure: What do you mean by "official"?
Shure: 你们这些回去都不能说是吧
Shure: You guys can't say that when you go back, right?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure的女友:我们这都不是CP
Shure's GF: We're not even a couple.
Shure: 哦好好好
Shure: Oh, alright, alright.
男嘉宾:我们我们这个
Male guest: We, we...
Katrina: 我看用手机拍
Katrina: I think we should use the phone to shoot.
Shure的女友:咦不要
Shure's GF: Oh no.
Katrina:  我试试给你们拍一组壁纸出来
Katrina: Let me try to take some wallpaper shots for you guys.
Jake:两个ego币
Jake: Two ego coins.
Shure: 给人笑醒酒了你知道吗
Shure: You know, people laugh to sober up.
Shure的女友:呵呵sorry尊重摄影师好吗
Shure's GF: Haha, sorry, respect the photographer, okay?
Shure:  怎怎么看摄影师
Shure: How do you see the photographer?
Shure的女友:怎么看
Shure's GF: How to see?
Shure的女友:你看
Shure's GF: You see.
男嘉宾:就你随便看个地方吧
Male guest: Just look anywhere you like.
男嘉宾:没有入镜
Male guest: Not in the frame.
男嘉宾:看地上然后你看啊
Male guest: Look at the ground, and then you look, okay?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 哈哈不准笑场
Katrina: Haha, no laughing on set.
Shure的女友:就是我们俩这个情况比较复杂
Shure's GF: The situation between us is quite complicated.
Shure的女友:你知道吗
Shure's GF: You know?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jack: 什么情况比较复杂
Jack: What situation is complicated?
Jake:啊什么叫复杂什么叫复杂
Jake: Ah, what do you mean by complicated?
Lucia:哦在在在摸鱼群摸鱼群
Lucia: Oh, in the fishing group, the fishing group.
Jack: 什么叫复杂
Jack: What's complicated?
Katrina: 拍 拍 拍到非公开群里
Katrina: Shoot, shoot, shoot it into the private group.
男嘉宾:哪里复杂
Male guest: What's complicated?
Shure的女友:sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry.
Shure: 没有没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no, no, no.
Shure的女友:不是他看我我看他
Shure's GF: It's not that he looks at me and I look at him.
Jake: 你要给我们送一集多少信息
Jake: How much information do you want to give us in one episode?
Shure的女友:我们俩会笑场
Shure's GF: We both will laugh.
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's okay.
女嘉宾:好看呐可以截一下
Female guest: It looks good, can you take a screenshot?
Jack: 怎么复杂
Jack: How is it complicated?
Jake:咱能飙一下午咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep this up for an entire afternoon?
Jack: 复杂在哪
Jack: Where is it complicated?
Jake:咱能飙得了不
Jake: Can we keep this up?
Jack: 到时候到时候这涉及到一个问题
Jack: At that time, it involves a problem.
Jack: 为什么复杂然后发给修硕他
Jack: Why is it complicated and then send it to Shure?
Jack: 发给修硕填填填答案呢
Jack: Send it to Shure to fill in the answers.
Shure的女友:后彩是吧
Shure's GF: It's a post-production thing, right?
Jack: 那个灰鸟灰得什么情况笑场
Jack: The grey bird, what's the situation with the laughter?
Shure: 来吧模特配合一下吧
Shure: Come on, models, let's cooperate a bit.
Shure的女友:等会我我我缓一下那个笑OK
Shure's GF: Wait a minute, I need to catch my breath, that laugh, okay.
男嘉宾:你俩能互相看一下吗
Male guest: Can you two look at each other?
Jack: 一点都不想看见他们
Jack: Don't want to see them at all.
男嘉宾:快快快
Male Guest: Quick, quick, quick
Shure:  互相看一下
Shure: Look at each other
Shure: 来配合摄影师一下
Shure: Let's cooperate with the photographer
Jack: 这这个看法不太不太正常
Jack: This view is not quite normal
Katrina: 你俩别整的像暧昧气一样行吗
Katrina: Can you two stop acting all flirty?
Jack: 你们俩搞得像你们俩
Jack: You two are making it seem like...
Jack: 现在还在害羞非常暧昧
Jack: You're still shy and very flirty
Shure:  没有
Shure: No
Jack: 所以是暧昧期吗
Jack: So, are you in the flirting stage?
Jack: 啊
Jack: Ah
Jack: 看着也不像啊
Jack: Doesn't look like it though
Jake:多久了 我也不懂我也不懂
Jake: How long has it been? I don't get it
男嘉宾:我也不懂我也很好奇
Male Guest: I don't get it either, I'm really curious
Jake:回去你自己飙啊
Jake: Go back and do it yourself then
男嘉宾:最后两张
Male Guest: Last two shots
Jake: 哈哈哈 我是飙不了的
Jake: Hahaha, I can't do it
Shure: 来来来必须给
Shure: Come on, come on, you have to give it
Jack: 到正到时问起就哎放
Jack: When the time comes, just let it go
Shure的女友:OK
Shure: OK
Jake:这玩意彪不了啦
Jake: This thing can't be done
Shure的女友:干嘛给自己
Shure: Why give it to yourself
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on
Katrina: 理解不了
Katrina: I don't get it
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:拍破防了 我草
Jake: Took a shot and broke the defense, damn
Jake:拍到了吧是吧
Jake: Got the shot, right?
男嘉宾:ok
Male Guest: OK
Jake:反正我们是都录了
Jake: Anyway, we recorded it all
男嘉宾:没电了
Male Guest: Out of battery
男嘉宾:看不见
Male Guest: Can't see
Jake: 挺好
Jake: Pretty good
Shure: 是的都是我们配的一环
Shure: Yes, it's all part of our plan
Jake:我觉得是第一个学习机里有接吻片的
Jake: I think it's the first learning machine with kissing scenes
Jake: 第一视角接吻照片
Jake: First-person kissing photos
Shure: 怎么以后以后以后
Shure: How about in the future, in the future
Jack: 我刚我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I just miss?
Jake:马上给他们看一眼
Jake: Show them quickly
Shure:  所有那个学生会议都要邀请我俩去亲一下是吧
Shure: All student meetings will invite us to kiss, right?
Jack: 我刚错过了什么
Jack: What did I just miss?
Tasha: 这里面有 上一张
Tasha: There's a previous one in here
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure:  对对对 上一张
Shure: Yes, yes, yes, the previous one.
Jake:我们第一张图片配合第一张图片就是这个哇
Jake: Our first picture matches with the first picture, it's this one.
Jack: 让我看看 来来来先先
Jack: Let me see, come on, come on, first.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Katrina: 看看看
Katrina: Let's see.
Katrina:  拍到了吗看看
Katrina: Did you get it? Let's see.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Jake:啊好妙啊
Jake: Ah, it's so wonderful.
Jack: 看了一下正点啊
Jack: Looked at it, it's perfect.
Shure的女友:分手了只要钱到位也没关系
Shure: It's fine to break up as long as the money is right.
Shure: 可以可以过去在亲的这是没有问题
Shure: Sure, sure, it's fine to kiss, no problem.
Jack: 分手一钱给到位也没问题
Jack: Break up, as long as the money is right, no problem.
Nicous: 分手了也没有关系吗
Nicous: Is it okay to break up?
Shure: 又不是没分过
Shure: It's not like it's the first time.
Shure的女友:要不然怎么会说情况很复杂呢
Shure's GF: Otherwise, why would they say it's complicated?
男嘉宾:有经验了都
Male Guest: They have experience.
Katrina: 不是哥们不玩了走了
Katrina: No, the bros are done, let's go.
Shure的女友:要不总是说四个呢
Shure's GF: Otherwise, why always say four?
男嘉宾:那看来是非常的复杂
Male Guest: It seems very complicated.
Jack: 这关系真的是很复杂
Jack: This relationship is really complicated.
Shure: 没有没有我没有
Shure: No, no, I don't have.
Shure: 没没必要没必要
Shure: No need, no need.
Shure: 先放着吧
Shure: Just leave it there.
Jake:抽两根要
Jake: Take two.
Jack: 这Paty活动适合拍照
Jack: This party activity is good for photos.
Jake: 该唱歌的人在那呢
Jake: The person who should be singing is over there.
Shure的女友:没事吧
Shure's GF: It's okay?
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
男嘉宾:唱歌唱歌
Male Guest: Sing, sing.
Jake:该唱歌的人在这整活了
Jake: The person who should be singing is here, doing stuff.
Jack: 唱啊开唱唱唱唱唱
Jack: Sing, start singing, sing, sing, sing.
Lucia:哎好看好看我觉得好看的
Lucia: Hey, it looks good, I think it looks good.
Shure: 啊唱唱唱唱唱唱唱什么
Shure: Ah, sing, sing, sing, sing, sing, sing, sing what?
Jake:整活了太忙了
Jake: Too busy doing stuff.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 我们要唱什么来着
Shure: What are we supposed to sing?
Shure: 是不是说说说给大家
Shure: Should we say, say, say to everyone?
Shure: 我的我的我的teammates
Shure: My, my, my teammates.
Shure:  我的我的roommates呢
Shure: Where are my roommates?
Shure:  roommates上里面调小药水去了
Shure: The roommates went to get some potions.
Jake: 这这你调酒去了
Jake: You're making drinks?
Lucia:你有teammates你不是说好了我自己solo吗
Lucia: You have teammates? Didn't you say you'd go solo?
女嘉宾:不是说好了我自己solo吗
Female Guest: Didn't you say you'd go solo?
Jake:solo 对呀
Jake: Solo, yes.
Shure: 什么solo不是
Shure: What solo? No.
Jake:solo dancer
Jake: Solo dancer.
Alice:真没走过路姐们
Alice: Never walked this path before, girls.
Shure: 唉
Shure: Sigh.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 没关系你想要哪张就哪张
Tasha: It's okay, pick whichever one you want.
Shure: 咋啦
Shure: What's up?
Shure的女友:你手里拿瓶酒干什么
Shure's GF: Why are you holding a bottle of wine?
Shure: 不不上去还是在下边上去是吗
Shure: Shouldn't I go up or stay down here?
Jake: 哎都行听你的
Jake: Ah, whatever, it's up to you.
Jack: 都行啊
Jack: Anything's fine.
Shure: 那下边中下边吧你去拿着吧
Shure: Then stay down here, you hold it.
Jake: 行在下面呆着吧
Jake: Fine, stay down here.
男嘉宾:那可能真的限制了一些你的视野
Male Guest: That might really have limited your view.
男嘉宾:你要拿一帮新的
Male Guest: You need a new one.
男嘉宾:就拿这个
Male Guest: Just take this one.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
男嘉宾:你要新的还是直接抽两根
Male Guest: Do you want a new one or just take two?
Katrina: 我要抽纸
Katrina: I want tissue.
Shure:  好科目
Shure: Okay, good subject.
Katrina:  受不了又被刺激到
Katrina: Can't stand it, I'm triggered again.
刘婷:我的天啊
Liu Ting: Oh my god.
Katrina: 今晚听一百遍唯一
Katrina: Listening to "The Only" a hundred times tonight.
Shure:  我的我的iPad去哪了
Shure: Where did my iPad go?
Tasha:都到了呀
Tasha: Everything's here.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina: 胆子小的一逼
Katrina: Scaredy-cat.
Katrina: 我说胆子小的一逼
Katrina: I said, scaredy-cat.
Shure:  人就在这边不要瞎说啥
Shure: The person is right here, don't talk nonsense.
Shure:  哈哈哈 行
Shure: Hahaha, alright.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure:  什么什么哎哎哎哎哎哎哎哎哎哎
Shure: What, what, hey hey hey hey hey hey hey.
Katrina: 什么东西呀什么东西呀
Katrina: What's this, what's this?
Katrina:  你们俩个不要瞎说
Katrina: You two, don't talk nonsense.
Katrina:  他们俩个天天造我谣的
Katrina: They keep spreading rumors about me every day.
Katrina:  我的roommates
Katrina: My roommates.
Shure:  所以我的iPad放哪了
Shure: So where did I put my iPad?
刘婷:哎呦果然是有人报销
Liu Ting: Oh, someone really reimbursed it.
Shure:  哎 我的iPad
Shure: Hey, my iPad.
Shure:  谁记得我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Does anyone remember where I put my iPad?
Shure:  我的iPad放哪儿
Shure: Where's my iPad?
Jake:会有这种数据我靠
Jake: There's data like this? Damn.
Shure:  你有印象吗
Shure: Do you remember?
Lucia:你试试那个寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: Try using the Find My iPhone feature.
Jake: 哦你在找吗
Jake: Oh, are you looking for it?
Lucia:不是
Lucia: No.
Shure: 没有我的iPad
Shure: My iPad is missing.
Lucia:修硕不是找不到
Lucia: Shure can't find it.
Shure:  忘记了放哪了
Shure: I forgot where I put it.
Lucia:我说可以试试寻找我的iPhone的功能
Lucia: I said you can try the Find My iPhone feature.
Jake: 咋的呀
Jake: What's up?
Jake: 不是这个不是这个薇薇的
Jake: Isn't this Tasha's?
Lucia:这个应该是薇薇的吧
Lucia: This should be Tasha's, right?
Jake: 二楼没有吗
Jake: Not on the second floor?
Shure:  你有看到我的iPad吗
Shure: Did you see my iPad?
Shure的女友:在楼上
Shure: It's upstairs.
Shure: 是吗 你看到啦
Shure: Really? You saw it?
Shure的女友:我看到了
Shure: I saw it.
Shure:  哦哦在架子上呢
Shure: Oh, it's on the shelf.
Shure的女友:在那个那个那个水池边上
Shure: By the sink.
Shure: 对对对对
Shure: Right, right, right.
Shure: 想起来了
Shure: I remember now.
Shure: 我们要不把这一套都拿下去吧
Shure: How about we take all of this downstairs?
Shure: 二楼活动或者外面都行
Shure: We can have the activity on the second floor or outside.
Shure: 能能插这个
Shure: Can we plug this in?
Shure: 我没没开
Shure: I didn't turn it on.
Shure: 没开电脑
Shure: It's on.
Shure: 开了
Shure: 谁把我音箱给拔了
Shure: Who unplugged my speaker?
Shure: 要不通力合作给它拿下去
Shure: How about we work together to take it downstairs?
Shure: 那就都拿下去吧
Shure: Let's take it all downstairs.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 拔了吧拔了吧
Shure: Unplug it.
Shure: 都拔了
Shure: Unplug everything.
Shure: 都拔 拔了吧
Shure: Pull them all out. Pull them all out.
Shure: 都拔都拔下来
Shure: Pull them all down.
Shure: 等一下啊等一下
Shure: Wait a second, wait a second.
Shure: 等一下这个
Shure: Wait a second, this one.
Shure: 我想今晚就
Shure: I think tonight...
Shure: 因为leader要找我
Shure: Because the leader is looking for me.
Shure: 在上面吧
Shure: Up there, right?
Jake:哎呀要上去了
Jake: Oh, he’s going up.
Shure: 他在上面活动
Shure: He’s doing something up there.
Jack: 既然你们都已经计划完了
Jack: Since you guys have already planned it...
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 那在上面活动吧
Shure: Then let's do it up there.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 虽然上面的氛围肯定稍逊色一点
Shure: Although the atmosphere up there is definitely a bit lacking.
Shure: 都插回原来
Shure: Plug everything back in.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:要插电板吗
Jake: Do we need a power strip?
Shure: 不用了
Shure: No.
Jake:不用了 好嘞
Jake: No? Alright.
Nicous: 你音箱接上了没
Nicous: Did you connect the speakers?
Shure: 音箱他们都接一起了我记得
Shure: I remember they connected all the speakers together.
Shure: 对插这个
Shure: Yes, plug this in.
Jack: 这这个是个啥呀
Jack: What is this thing?
Shure: 这就是个声卡
Shure: This is a sound card.
Shure: 哎这要插线板
Shure: Hey, we need a power strip for this.
Shure: 谁把这个插线板拔下去了
Shure: Who unplugged the power strip?
Shure: 我打算就回去上两天班看看心情
Shure: I plan to go back to work for a couple of days and see how I feel.
Jake:我啊 拔下去的呀
Jake: It was me, I unplugged it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, come on.
Shure的女友:修
Shure's GF: Shure.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Yes?
Shure: 要钱嗯
Shure: Do you need money?
Shure: 你先
Shure: You first.
Shure: 谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jack: 来我给你主持一波
Jack: Let me host for you.
Nicous: 听说你今晚不走了走了
Nicous: I heard you’re not leaving tonight, right?
Shure: 我
Shure: Me?
Jake:啊你还要走啊
Jake: Oh, you’re still leaving?
Jake:你不能走啊
Jake: You can't leave!
Shure: 我不能走么
Shure: Can't I leave?
Jake:你你也能走
Jake: You can leave too.
Shure: 我我主要
Shure: I mainly...
Shure: 我主要想
Shure: I mainly want...
Shure: 明
Shure: Tomorrow...
Jake:想干嘛想想毕业
Jake: What do you want to do, graduate?
Shure: 明天上班主要是
Shure: Mainly, I have work tomorrow.
Nicous: 明天上班
Nicous: Work tomorrow?
Shure: 明天
Shure: Tomorrow...
Jake:来插线板
Jake: Come, plug in the power strip.
Shure: 因为
Shure: Because...
Shure: 其实再再呆一天
Shure: Actually, staying another day...
Shure: 我翘了一周班
Shure: I've already skipped work for a week.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Jack: 哦血亏2100 至少2100
Jack: Oh, you’ve lost at least 2100.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Jake:带薪翘班还是啥
Jake: Skipping work with pay or what?
Jack: 你给他300一天网易少给他300一天
Jack: You give him 300 a day, NetEase deducts 300 a day.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 网易就150
Shure: NetEase only pays 150.
Shure: 我一天
Shure: For one day.
Jake:那你一直在我身上 对啊
Jake: So you've been with me all the time, yeah.
Lucia:哦 其实赚了
Lucia: Oh, actually you’ve earned.
Shure: 而而且
Shure: And, and...
Jake:对啊 那你回去干嘛
Jake: Yeah, so why go back?
Jake:那你回去干嘛
Jake: So why go back?
Katrina: 明天待一天还有300呢
Katrina: If you stay another day, you get another 300.
Shure: 也也也也有道理
Shure: That... that makes sense.
Jack: 对啊那那那
Jack: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 待一天吧待一天吧
Shure: I might as well stay another day.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 等一下等一下
Shure: Wait, wait.
Shure: 来 来
Shure: Come, come.
Jake:确实 就是顾大来摸鱼啦
Jake: Yep, just relax and slack off.
Jake:你们带着眼镜就行
Jake: Just wear glasses, it’s fine.
Shure: 来 我来我来
Shure: Come on, I'll do it.
Jake:干啥都行
Jake: Do whatever you want.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 插上了
Shure: Plugged in.
Katrina: 拍一下我们老板
Katrina: Take a picture of our boss.
Katrina: 哈哈哈拍一下我们提倡摸鱼的老板
Katrina: Hahaha, take a picture of our boss who encourages slacking off.
Katrina: 哈哈哈真好人
Katrina: Hahaha, such a good person.
Katrina: 睡到11点不带叫你醒的
Katrina: Sleeps until 11 without waking you up.
Jack: 是吗
Jack: Really?
Jack: 喂喂
Jack: Hey, hey.
Jake:咦 少个人少人是吧
Jake: Hmm, someone is missing, right?
Katrina: 少谁啊
Katrina: Who's missing?
Jake:坐地上可以
Katrina: 薇薇啊
Katrina: Tasha, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: 哦还有那个
Katrina: Oh, and also...
Katrina: 柯欣是吗
Katrina: Kexin, right?
Jake:柯欣
Jake: Kexin.
Jake:坐地上
Jake: Sitting on the floor.
Shure: 来吧我在703
Shure: Come on, I'm at 703.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我们没有排过任何一遍
Katrina: Hahaha, we never rehearsed any of this.
Katrina: 真的的可以吗
Katrina: Really, is it okay?
Shure: 可以
Shure: It's okay.
Jake:这是默契
Jake: This is chemistry.
Jake:已经毕业了
Jake: Already graduated.
Shure: 对就是默契
Shure: Yeah, it's chemistry.
Jake:对这是提前培养的默契
Jake: Yes, this is pre-developed chemistry.
Katrina: 等等等薇薇他们回来要不要一起
Katrina: Wait, wait, when Tasha and the others come back, should we do it together?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable tonight.
男嘉宾:不如在这个时候
Male Guest: How about at this moment...
男嘉宾:我们要留下来一种普通人
Male Guest: we leave behind something for ordinary people.
Katrina: 哈哈每天都要弹一遍
Katrina: Hahaha, we have to play it every day.
Jake:薇薇走了
Jake: Tasha is gone.
Katrina: 来就打卡来了
Katrina: Came to clock in.
Jack: 哎呀来来来
Jack: Hey, hey, come on, come on.
Katrina: 每天都是了遍普通人
Katrina: Every day, we are ordinary people.
Katrina: 每天吃吃喝喝弹弹琴睡睡觉
Katrina: Every day, eating, drinking, playing the piano, and sleeping.
Shure: 是不是有这个东西我记得
Shure: Is there such a thing, I remember?
Shure: 是不是还有全民K歌
Shure: Is there also a karaoke app?
Shure: 全民k歌
Shure: Karaoke app.
Shure: 没事没事来吧
Shure: No problem, no problem, come on.
Shure: 我的我的我的朋友就是
Shure: My, my, my friend is...
Shure: 不是不是不是
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure: 首先有一个我们这个这个
Shure: First, we have this, this...
Shure: EGO life大家庭集体要完成的一个任务
Shure: EGO life family task we need to complete.
Shure: 叫做哎不是任务给大家
Shure: It's called, oh no, a task for everyone.
Shure: 准精心准备的一个节目叫做晴天啊
Shure: Carefully prepared a program called "Sunny Day."
Shure: 想必大家都听过
Shure: I bet everyone has heard of it.
Shure: 没错没想到吧
Shure: That's right, didn't see that coming, huh?
Katrina: New boy 没排
Katrina: New boy didn't line up.
Jack: 来吧谁唱谁主唱
Jack: Come on, who's singing? Who's the lead singer?
Jack: 你主唱你就拿着话筒
Jack: If you're the lead singer, you hold the microphone.
Jack: 我拿话筒你
Jack: I'll hold the microphone, you...
Nicous: 你拿话筒你
Nicous: You hold the microphone, you...
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 那个凳子帮我往前放一点
Shure: Move that chair a bit forward for me.
Katrina: 好一起唱呗
Katrina: Okay, let's sing together.
Shure: 来吧大家会的就一起唱
Shure: Come on, everyone who knows it, sing along.
Katrina: 给你拍个绝美
Katrina: I'll take a beautiful picture of you.
Lucia:你要擦那个相机吗还是
Lucia: Are you going to wipe the camera or...
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done.
Katrina: 好 好听
Katrina: Okay, sounds good.
男嘉宾:少个字
Male Guest: Missing a word.
Katrina: 哎 可以
Katrina: Ah, it's fine.
Tasha:嗯  好
Tasha: Hmm, okay.
Shure: 对着点我嘴
Shure: Point it at my mouth.
Shure: 话筒一点升收不进去
Shure: Raise the microphone a bit, it's not picking up.
Jack: ok ok说声对不起
Jack: Okay, okay, say sorry.
Shure: 哈哈哈喂喂哎
Shure: Hahaha, hello, hey.
Katrina: 这是这是
Katrina: This is, this is...
Katrina: 这是彩排啊
Katrina: This is a rehearsal?
Shure: 啊对刚刚是彩排
Shure: Ah, yes, that was a rehearsal.
Shure: 哈哈哈刚才是试音好吧
Shure: Hahaha, it was just a sound check, okay?
男嘉宾:主要是试音
Male Guest: Mainly a sound check.
Shure: 好吧也也能看到
Shure: Alright, you can also see it...
Katrina: 试音
Katrina: Sound check.
男嘉宾:他这个看不到词
Male Guest: He can't see the lyrics.
男嘉宾:对对对
Male Guest: Yes, yes.
Shure: 也也能看到
Shure: You can also see it...
Nicous: 这词有点小
Nicous: The lyrics are a bit small.
男嘉宾:大
Male Guest: Big.
男嘉宾:可以可以
Male Guest: It's fine, it's fine.
Shure: 可以看到可以看到啊
Shure: You can see it, you can see it, yeah.
Katrina: OK
Katrina: OK.
Katrina: 那你要面对这边面吗
Katrina: Do you want to face this side?
男嘉宾:那你可以重来还是接着来
Male Guest: Can you start over or continue?
Shure: 从头来
Shure: Start from the beginning.
男嘉宾:从头来从头来
Male Guest: From the beginning, from the beginning.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Shure: 保证
Shure: Promise.
Katrina: 有勇气
Katrina: Courage.
Lucia:没事没事这个不是玻璃
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay, this isn't glass.
Shure: 啥玩意碎了
Shure: What broke?
Lucia:这是个啥呀
Lucia: What is this?
女嘉宾:杨老板杨老板
Female Guest: Jake, Jake.
Shure: 下一首还有还有下一首
Shure: Next song, there's another one, another song.
Nicous: 加个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano.
男嘉宾:还有下一首
Male Guest: Another song.
Katrina: 你想弹什么你弹
Katrina: Play whatever you want.
Nicous: 前面加一个钢琴
Nicous: Add a piano at the front.
Katrina: 来啊
Katrina: Sure.
Jack: 可以
Jack: Okay.
Jack: 流沙
Jack: Quicksand.
Shure: 我们是不是还说要唱new boy来着啊
Shure: Didn't we also say we were going to sing "New Boy"?
Katrina: 都行都行
Katrina: Anything is fine.
Katrina: 反正发现就还是咱几个人
Katrina: Anyway, it's just the few of us.
男嘉宾:唱什么
Male Guest: What to sing?
Katrina: 那随便唱
Katrina: Then sing whatever.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:对都在掌握中
Jake: Yes, everything is under control.
Jake:你随便唱
Jake: Sing whatever you want.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything is under control.
Shure: 那个XBZ你
Shure: That XBZ you...
Nicous: 你把麦关了
Nicous: Turn off the mic.
Shure: 你 你弹一个D调的卡农的和弦会吗
Shure: Can you play a D major Canon chord?
Nicous: 可以
Nicous: Sure.
Shure: 不不 你就弹D调卡农和弦就行
Shure: No, no, just play the D major Canon chord.
Katrina: 一切都在掌握中
Katrina: Everything is under control.
Nicous: 很高级
Nicous: Very advanced.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Katrina: 就么看我房间还是很好看的哈哈
Katrina: See, my room still looks great, haha.
Shure: 找一下吧
Shure: Let's find it.
Shure: 哎呀歌词就行
Shure: Oh, just the lyrics will do.
Shure: 这个
Shure: This
Shure: 让大家
Shure: Let everyone
Jake:对是其他挺费劲的
Jake: Yeah, it's quite a hassle for others.
Shure: 能能能找明白不
Shure: Can you figure it out?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Nicous: 是这个吗
Nicous: Is it this one?
Shure: 差不多吧
Shure: Close enough.
Shure: 相信你
Shure: I trust you.
刘婷:怎么顶格了
Liu Ting: Why is it aligned?
Shure: 第一个是这个
Shure: The first one is this.
Shure: 拍什么曲子
Shure: What song are we shooting?
Shure: new boy
Shure: New Boy
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake:不行不行
Jake: No, no, no.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Jake:得上来摸鱼
Jake: You have to come here to slack off.
Jake:翘班不行
Jake: Skipping work is not okay.
Shure: one
Shure: One
Shure: two
Shure: Two
Shure: one two three
Shure: One, two, three
Shure: 打这个是吗
Shure: Hit this, right?
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This one, this one.
Shure: 我从这调
Shure: I'll adjust from here.
Shure: OK 好
Shure: OK, good.
男嘉宾:喂
Male Guest: Hello?
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Tasha:好
Tasha: Good.
男嘉宾:还有点大
Male Guest: It's still a bit loud.
男嘉宾:稍为有点大得调小点
Male Guest: It's a bit loud, needs to be turned down.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure: 你的
Shure: Yours.
Jake:哈哈哈沙雕
Jake: Hahaha, silly.
Jake:来来来
Jake: Come, come, come.
Katrina: 差不多 嗯
Katrina: Almost, yeah.
Shure: 行了行了行了可以了可以了
Shure: Alright, alright, alright, it's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 哈哈哈谱还没对象
Katrina: Hahaha, the score doesn't even have a partner.
Katrina: 结束了
Katrina: It's over.
Shure: 来吧你你的难忘今宵了吧该
Shure: Come on, it's your turn for "Unforgettable Tonight," right?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jack: 啊 谁难忘今宵了
Jack: Ah, who's singing "Unforgettable Tonight"?
Nicous: 那你调下声
Nicous: Then adjust the sound.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 人呢还有一个
Shure: Where's the other person?
Shure: 还有一个XBZ同学要为大家带来的一首歌曲
Shure: There's still one more student, XBZ, who will bring us a song.
Shure: 叫
Shure: Called...
Nicous: 谢彬竹和修硕的
Nicous: It's by Xie Binzhu and Shure.
Shure: 没有我没有我
Shure: No, it's not me.
Nicous: 你这比我重要了
Nicous: You're more important than me.
Shure: 这个
Shure: What...
Shure: 我比你重要什么
Shure: How am I more important than you?
Shure: 我给你选一个好听的音色就好了
Shure: I'll just pick a good tone for you.
Nicous: 给我切换一下
Nicous: Switch it for me.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Nicous: 用手指切换
Nicous: Switch it with your finger.
Shure: 来吧XBZ同学
Shure: Come on, XBZ.
Shure: 没有他
Shure: He's not here.
Katrina: 呵呵 这弹出来
Katrina: Haha, this just popped out.
男嘉宾:有点想哭了 音乐出来就想哭
Male Guest: I feel like crying, the music makes me want to cry.
Katrina: 这是背景音吧
Katrina: Is this background music?
男嘉宾:这加了特效音乐
Male Guest: This has special effects music added.
Jack: 准备 准准备开哭
Jack: Get ready, get ready to start crying.
Katrina: 这什么歌
Katrina: What song is this?
男嘉宾:难忘今宵
Male Guest: Unforgettable Tonight.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Shure: 今夜我们在此欢聚
Shure: Tonight we gather here joyfully.
Alice:我靠
Alice: Oh my god.
男嘉宾:哎哟喂
Male Guest: Oh my.
Katrina: 说不清
Katrina: Can't explain it.
Shure: 今夜我们在此快乐
Shure: Tonight we gather here happily.
Nicous: 再再来一点
Nicous: A bit more.
男嘉宾:已经开饮一天了
Male Guest: We've been drinking all day.
Alice:这什么环节啊
Alice: What's this segment?
Katrina: 忘记今宵
Katrina: Forget about tonight.
Shure的女友:难忘今宵
Shure: Unforgettable Tonight.
Jake:赶上clothing了
Jake: It's about to close.
Shure: 我们相聚一堂
Shure: We gather together.
Shure: 在这ego house
Shure: Here at the ego house.
Jack: 什么呀
Jack: What is this?
Alice:有点抽象
Alice: It's a bit abstract.
Jake:我跟你哈哈哈哈
Jake: I'm telling you, hahaha.
刘婷:ego house
Liu Ting: ego house
Jack: 顺间就服气了
Jack: Instantly impressed
女嘉宾:你们坐吧
Female guest: You guys take a seat
Shure: 我们难忘今宵
Shure: We will never forget tonight
Shure: 我们难忘未来
Shure: We will never forget the future
Jack: 难忘未来什么
Jack: What do you mean by "never forget the future"?
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈你忘什么东西
Jake: Hahaha, what are you forgetting?
男嘉宾:我笑死了
Male guest: I'm dying of laughter
Katrina: 还没过呢就难忘
Katrina: We haven't even gotten there and it's unforgettable?
Shure: 我们难忘过去
Shure: We will never forget the past
Katrina: 好夺目啊
Katrina: So dazzling
Shure: 来吧 朋友
Shure: Come on, friends
Jake:快进门
Jake: Hurry inside
Shure: 牵着你的手
Shure: Holding your hand
女嘉宾:要退票了
Female guest: We need to refund the tickets
Shure: 就让
Shure: Just let
Shure: 昨天的烦恼都忘掉
Shure: Yesterday's worries fade away
Jake:傻瓜
Jake: Silly
Shure: 去迎接明天的快乐吧
Shure: Let's embrace tomorrow's happiness
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jack: 还啊的一声
Jack: Even an "ah" sound
Shure: 多好啊
Shure: How great
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Nicous: 我有点感觉这个谱子不太对啊
Nicous: I feel like the melody isn't quite right
Shure: 挺好的
Shure: It's fine
男嘉宾:没有
Male guest: No
Jake:这叫离谱你懂吗
Jake: This is what we call "off-key," got it?
Shure: 这个我们就叫做离谱对吧
Shure: We just call this "off-key," right?
Jack: 没有
Jack: No
Jack: 滚你这看起来就不算有谱不能叫离谱
Jack: Get lost, this isn't even considered on-key to be called off-key
Nicous: 他没有背歌词
Nicous: He didn't memorize the lyrics
Nicous: 他在玩茶流鸡我草
Nicous: He's just playing around, damn
Jack: 让我猜他己经醉了
Jack: Let me guess, he's already drunk
Jake:哈哈已经唱完了
Jake: Hahaha, the song is already finished
Shure: 没有没有我们这就是诗朗诵环节
Shure: No, no, this is our poetry recitation segment
Jake:哎好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, fine
Shure: 难忘今宵表演者
Shure: Unforgettable tonight performers
Shure: Ego life全体成员
Shure: Ego life all members
Jake:啥 哈哈
Jake: What? Haha
Katrina: 立的都爬了
Katrina: Even the ones standing have fallen
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
男嘉宾:所以所以你们这一个礼拜
Male Guest: So, so, you guys this week...
女嘉宾:退票
Female Guest: Refund
男嘉宾:都是天天这么精神病吗
Male Guest: Have you been this crazy every day?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 新来的朋友啊
Shure: New friends, huh?
Shure: 我们每天都很快乐
Shure: We're happy every day.
Shure: 来吧快来到美好的ego life吧
Shure: Come on, join the wonderful ego life.
Jack: 美好啊是没有好那个好吧
Jack: Wonderful, huh? That's not true.
Shure: ego life是一个
Shure: Ego life is a...
Shure: 快乐的大家庭
Shure: A happy big family.
Shure: 是一个没有纷争的大家庭
Shure: A big family without conflicts.
Shure: 是一个完蛋
Shure: A perfect...
Shure: 我被美女包围了的大家庭
Shure: A big family where I'm surrounded by beauties.
Shure: Ego life
Shure: Ego life.
Jack: 就这句话比较现实
Jack: That's the most realistic part.
Shure: 带给了我快乐
Shure: It brings me happiness.
Katrina: 这是诗歌朗诵
Katrina: Is this a poetry recital?
Shure: 带给了我金币
Shure: It brings me gold coins.
Jake:Ego Coin
Jake: Ego Coin.